I'm just proud of you cuz I'm looking at
your setup this guy hailing it I wanted
to have you one when he was shitty
because it looked like the other side of
your room people say everybody was like
is that the other side of Steve's room
you know what kind of night I laughed at
it every time you came did my podcast
back when you always referred to my room
as a door my girlfriend you reveal it
that stuff we only did in the chat yeah
we never talked about that on your
podcast all right look we can edit that
horribly wrong dude when is the first
time we you know you like at least 10
years it might be no I don't know if
it's that long because it could be the
first time I knew that the comedies no
no no no all I remember dude can I can I
bring up a story no no but the first
time I have a comedy store all right
cool but the first time I met you was at
the Comedy Store just briefly Steve
Bobby's like this is my brother but the
first time we actually really hung out
is when I whipped you at FIFA at Bobby's
place really thought you were so you
were so upset yeah beat you now we got
to stream it we will be streaming FIFA
look out for that I remember walking up
to I was at the store and then I think
cuz your cuz you're probably used to
like you're sick of people like random
fans coming up to you in the hallway am
I sick of it truce I remember one time I
walked up to you and I go it was like
you we weren't really fully acquainted
we I don't know I went up to you I go
what's up man
you looked at me like Steve you're like
what what's up yeah because I go what's
that man give you a little bit of a
weirdo I'm pretty weird yeah you're
[ __ ] weirdo you can't just walk up to
people and
like you know I am weird yeah no no I've
done I am a weird I do weird things yeah
you have a weird side I am you make you
creeping me out
I am weird yeah I I do weird things
you're getting the cat I mean you're
getting big names
well trotted into the names you're
getting I can't get those people yes you
can no right I could give with the names
I get it right right you get I can't get
someone who's with a Yeti I don't know
them I don't hang out at skate parks in
like you know I would go to the B rapper
studios and wait in the bag for them to
come I'm gonna let you say those things
because I love you as a brother
I'm do what you're doing man no no I'm
doing what you're doing you've been
doing this longer than I have
no no no in the game no no no you're
doing very well
oh my god you're doing very well so if
you haven't subscribed yet we all ready
told you to my subscribers are your
podcast we should start the whole
episode no we're good because I'm
already in my head like I should have
said this I shouldn't bring this I just
wanna let you know I love you I look at
you as a brother I feel the same way I
wish you were you were the it was like
brother there Bobby is it you know